[Music]
with knives out an extremely popular and
successful representative of the
so-called hudani genre was released
shortly before the pandemic the story by
director and screenwriter ryan johnson
which could undoubtedly have been
written by agatha christie sanded on an
unsolved death and the brilliant
detective benue blah played by bond
actor daniel craig shortly after the
movie's release in early 2020 johnson
clarified that knife sound had been
planned as a trilogy and that they would
like to continue ben roblin's quirky
adventures now that john's nana's
co-producer ran berkman has signed a 469
million dollar deal with netflix initial
information on the cast as well as the
planned release of the sequel is
available following the conclusion of
production last september accordingly
ethan hawke dave bautista jessica
hanwick kate hudson and even fight club
star edward norton are to be part of the
cast in the upcoming installment wonder
vision actress catherine hunt and soul
singer janelle monae are among the cast
as well the top class stars of the
previous film on the other hand are no
longer expected to be involved since the
story of the thrombey family came to
close at the end of part 1. there's
still no info on the news story however
the movie is scheduled for release on
netflix this fall
last year the movie adaption of the
action game of the same name mortal
kombat was released in fact the
blockbuster with its rating only seemed
to have convinced audiences to a
mediocre degree yathos and charge at new
line cinema have decided to make a new
attempt with his sequel moon9 and
umbrella academy author jeremy slater
has been hired to tell the story as the
use magazine deadline recently announced
likewise dwayne johnson spoke out and
announced that he is currently working
on another movie adaption of a video
game it is supposed to be badass and
brutal which would fit pretty well with
mortal kombat 2 even though johnson has
not explicitly mentioned the name so far
sadly there is no information on the
plot and cast of the sequel yet and is
also unknown whether director simon
mcquite will be back so for now
we will have to wait and see but of
course we will keep you up to date on
any news
soon the time will come and we can again
see jason statham and the sequel of meg
the movie is titled mac 2 the trench and
will feature statham and the famous
prehistoric giant shark megalodon ben
wheatley will direct the film which will
be shot in two gigantic underwater tanks
at warner brothers studios this means
saying goodbye not only to new zealand
as a filming location but also to john
turtletop who was the director of the
first part the movie is said to be
strongly based on the second volume of
the book by steve alton and in addition
to stay the mask jones taylor will also
bring back chinese actress li bang bang
as oceanologist xi jin zhang it will be
particularly exciting to see how
director wheatley realized the sequel as
he has not yet been able to gain any
experience in the field of underwater
horror regardless we hope for many
visually stunning scenes with a
megalodon and look forward to back to
the trench an exact release date is not
known as of yet but we expect a release
in the coming year
following the box office success of
godzilla versus cognitive subsequent
release on hbo max another streaming
provider has now secured a share of the
monsterverse as a series for apple tv
pluses in production which is to tie in
with the story of the godzilla zolo film
the storyline focuses on a family that
has an unsuspected connection to the
monster world and gets to the bottom of
it in the series as the show progresses
they are also expected to encounter the
sinister monarch organization showrun on
the series is star trek enterprise
producer chris black who will also be
writing the script along with comic book
author matt fraction how legendary will
continue the monster verse apart from
the apple tv plus series is not known
yet but the godzilla vs kong sequel son
of kong is still on the agenda
in spring 2020 disney announced work on
a series adaption of the popular percy
jackson fantasy series and now casting
is said to have already started fans of
the book series who have seen the two
movies percy jackson the olympians the
lighting thief and percy jackson sea of
monsters are likely to be extremely
skeptical about the planned series
adaption as the movie spin-offs were not
well received by either fans or critics
for the series however the prognosis is
already looking a lot better because on
the one hand book author and percy
jackson creator rick ryden is heavily
involved in the production and on the
other hand disney will make sure that
this series also gets an appropriate
budget in fact ryan has even been signed
on as a co-writer for the pilot episode
aside from that he will be overseeing
the project as a producer together with
his wife rebecca ryden broadly speaking
the percy jackson book series revolves
around a contemporary world in which the
well-known greek deities exist and have
now set up the olympus not in greece but
in new york city as in the greek myths
the gods have also given birth to all
kinds of offspring some of them with
humans which in turn makes the children
demigods one such demigod is the
protagonist percy jackson who may be
mortal but has superpowers as the son of
the sea god poseidon we are definitely
eager to find out how the disney plus
series unfolds an official series start
is not known yet but we can likely
expect a release in the coming year
the past week saw another setback for
fans of the mission impossible series
according to news from the hollywood
reporter paramount has decided to
further delay mission impossible seven
and eight the seventh part which was
planned for this september will not be
released until july 14 2023 while
mission impossible 8 will even have to
be delayed until june 28 2024
whether the now almost unbearably long
wait will be worth it for fans of the
action series remains to be seen with
some spectacular reports about stunts
and the return of several actors from
the previous installments such as henry
cherny as eugene kittridge they are
trying to keep the fan in good spirits
for the moment
when game of thrones star peter dinklage
was a gaston comedian mark marin's wtf
podcast a few days ago no one would have
thought that his statement on the
upcoming snow white film adaption would
make such massive waves in a downright
rant the english accused disney of
double standards with regard to the
casting of the remake on the one hand
they cast the latin american actress
rachel ziegler as the protagonist but on
the other hand they still intend to tell
the story of the seven dwarfs who live
in a cave even though the seven dwarves
and the grim fairy tale do not live in a
cave but an ordinary house the 1.35
meter tall dinglage fears a hurtful
stereotypical portrayal of small people
if anything he said they should go all
in and revamp the entire story disney in
turn reacted in a flash with a statement
assuring that the stereotypes of the old
animated film would no longer be used
and that a different approach would be
chosen internally there is reportedly
talk of magical creatures instead of
seven dwarfs as the rep reported the
politically correct remake will then
hardly have anything in common with the
classic from 1937 after all snow white's
love interest as it's officially called
is no longer a prince or huntsman but a
robin hood-like figure who steals from
the rich and provides for his poor
friends so what are your thoughts can
disney's snow white remake win you over
with its approach of not offending
anyone or would you rather like to see a
classic movie adaption based on the 1937
model feel free to discuss with us in
the comments
this week we are happy to recommend our
new original for spider-man 4 to all of
you have already seen spider-man no way
home within barely 9 minutes you will be
up to date with the very latest news on
the sequel besides that you should not
miss the final trailer of uncharted on
our channel
[Music]
you